because the last time you guys were on
the show together Anthony and Greg they
did a boxing challenge and in a bit of a
shock result Anthony won heavyweight
champion of would beat so this time this
time we've got another judgement the
last time it was you know those boxing
things are you hit the box in there so
that's we did the last time this time
we've gone for one of those funfair a
test of strength machines okay
so if you'd like to bring in the machine
here it is
[Music]
come down to our message thread now the
two of you gotta send one you're gonna
have a bit of a faceoff in front of it
okay
okay we're taking this seriously yeah
we're taking it seriously and it's not
it's it is of strength with I believe
technique plays a huge part in knots all
right so Ken Brown is going to give us a
little bit of form before we do this if
you do your face off - your face off
come on come on
okay off you go
[Music]
[Applause]
the husband because he always delivers
it's the undisputed heavyweight champion
of the world to me
[Music]
right they call him I see looking at
then call him Korea the Korea because he
sometimes delivers unless he gets stuck
in traffic
[Applause]
first let's have you I thought that was
gonna be heavier okay
okay you go first you mind the cameras
here we go
so golf
[Applause]
well you might miss it as well
the Bell
[Applause]
okay Anthony why don't you help to D
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
could predicted that our about April of
her teens been canceled
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you